Hey guys!
This is Antoine Allen, award-winning filmmaker.
And my name is Lester Greene and I’m a producer,
actor, and published author.
This is Film Courage, diary series.
[Cultivating Success and Building Your Brand
in the Film Industry]
Lester: When I first started auditioning for
student films and short films and I met a
director by the name of Rickey Waymer and
he gave me my first role.
And ever since then I just fell in love with
acting.
I just love the idea of being in front of
the camera and being a different character,
that’s how I started.
Antoine: I started actually in the music business.
I used to manage up-and-coming talent and
I also used to do music videos.
And from there it was a great fill-in but
I felt limited.
So I wrote my first short film called SPLIT
/ DECISION and I won my first award and that
was it, that was like the love, love at first
sight.
[How we began collaborating]
Lester: Antione has a feature film called
LIFE IS TOO SHORT and Crystal Williams introduced
me to him and told me about the casting call
that he had so Antione looked at my reel and
he saw one thing that he liked.
Antoine: Just one.
Lester: It was just one thing and he said
“Yeah, I want this guy in my movie.”
And so ever since then we’ve just been knocking
out films.
Antoine: Yeah…I cast Lester because as a
filmmaker and as a writer you want to get
the top-notch talent you can on our level
to make your stories come to life.
So he was in my award-winning feature film
LIFE IS TOO SHORT and his role was really
powerful and from there I started doing more
films.
I always remembered him.
I said “Lester, you could do so much more.”
And sometimes it takes someone to see something
in you that you don’t see in yourself.
And from there we’ve just been knocking
out short films back to back to fulfill our
brand.
Lester: Yeah, he was just telling me that
it’s so important to create your own work.
Don’t wait for someone to cast you in a
film or someone to put you in a web series.
And so we just created…what was that…it
was the first short film that we did?
Antoine: So far it was like five short films
together.
And a lot of people say “Short films are
dead.”
It depends who you ask.
So four to five short films.
And what I did was I used those short films
to build the Antoine Allen brand and we’re
all part of the same brand.
[Build Your Brand]
And each short film won awards, we got short
films on TV.
Lester: CBS.
Antoine: CBS.
We had short films show nationally and we
won national awards.
And what that does is that builds your brand
and builds your calling card.
For me I wanted to give back to the film community
in a way that it felt like it would be effective.
So I started my own film festival called Validate
Yourself Film Festival.
And the reason I call it validate is because
I think for a lot of artists they look for
validation everywhere else except themselves.
I went to a few film festivals when I was
traveling the film festival circuit and some
festivals I just didn’t like how they were
treating filmmakers.
Some times it felt like the filmmaker should
be honored to even be at the festival.
A film festival and the filmmaker is partnership.
You can’t have a film festival without having
filmmakers and a filmmaker needs a festival,
so it’s a partnership.
It’s not lopsided.
I came from the music business and I realized
that if you’re a hiphop artist, mixtapes
or demos are kind of like your calling card.
So the short film is kind of like your calling
card.
You do enough of it, you flood the market.
I tell people all the time “You have to
grind like an indie, but move like a major.”
Lester: Ooohhh, say it again.
Antoine: Grind like an indie, move like a
major.
Lester: …And move like a major…ooohhh,
that’s nice.
Antoine: And what that means is as an indie
you do whatever you have to do.
Anything that’s possible, anything that
serves you’ve got to do it.
Move like a major is just because I have a
little bit of money, don’t mean my film
should look like an independent film.
Lester: Right.
Antoine: Do what you can to make your film
look bigger than what it is.
And like I said, working together and find
your partner.
Find someone that you can really connect with.
[Tell A Good Story]
Lester: A lot of people don’t have a good
story.
I learned that from this guy.
It’s so important to have a good story because
you’ll watch films and it will look pretty.
It will look great on the screen and everything
but there is no story, there is no substance,
nobody is reacting to it.
And we just finished shooting a short film
called RAW FOOTAGE, right?
And it screened at The Schomburg Center in
Harlem [New York] through the Omari Hardwick
Real to Reel Tour right.
And people were watching our short film and
they were feeling it, they were laughing,
they were joking around.
And then there was another film that aired
right…
Antoine: Crickets!
Lester: Yeah…crickets!
No reaction, no audience reaction.
And it looked great.
Antoine: And honestly the film that was getting
crickets looked way better than our's.
Lester: It did.
It looked better.
[Your Film’s Success Depends On The Audience]
Antoine: Better writing, better camera.
But…there was no engagement with the audience.
So at the end of the day, your film’s success
depends on the audience.
Lester: Right.
Absolutely.
Antoine: Not the best camera, not the best
colorist because that doesn’t sell tickets,
the audience member does.
Lester: Right.
Let me give you another example we screened
our film MAMMA’S BOY at Necessary Studios,
right?
And we’re watching the film and I’m watching
the film for the first time and I was crying.
And Antoine was telling me that people in
the audience were crying, too.
It was amazing and that very same film is
going to be screening where?
Antoine: At the African-American Academy in
Africa.
Lester: In Africa!
Africa guys.
That’s an incredible festival.
I didn’t even know anything about it, Antoine
told me it’s like the Oscars in Africa.
Antoine: So we did a story in Queens [New
York] that traveled all the way to Africa.
It touched someone all the way in Africa.
So you just never know.
[Use Your Short Films To Market Yourself]
This video is really for you to use your short
films as marketing tools.
There are only so many festivals you can submit
to, so do things outside of a festival.
Do your own screenings, do your own premieres.
There are a few websites out there that you
can submit your films to try and get on TV.
One of them is shorts.tv.
Another one for more African-American filmmakers
is AfricanAmericanShortFilms.com.
There are a few other ones out there.
[Get Over Fear]
And there are so many different outlets to
show your short films.
My journey of how I accomplished so much,
first is I had to get over fear.
Fear is one of the main reasons why most people
are living a life they are not happy about.
Once I got over that I had to realize this
is my own voice and have faith in myself.
God have me amazing talent and I don’t want
to waste it.
Right now I am 37 years old.
I officially got into the film business (without
stopping, without pausing, without tippy-toeing)
at 31.
Right now I am at 37 and so far I’ve got
one feature film under my belt that won 15
awards (domestically and internationally).
I never traveled outside of the U.S. but my
first feature film took me to Spain, France,
I went to Africa.
And also I was in a publication book that
is now iTunes for the top 100 indie filmmakers
in the world.
I made number five on the list.
And the bigger accomplishment I think I had
was helping other people.
When I saw Lester (when he first met me) he
was just trying to find his way.
Now he’s an author, award-winning producer,
award-winning actor, and that’s my bigger
accomplishment.
And all those pieces happened because I listened
to myself and God.
[Do Your Research And Continuously Build Your
Knowledge]
And also to, research sites like Film Courage.
Film Courage is another tool that I use to
get information.
Lester: Oooohh…yeah.
Antoine: So Film Courage, they don’t know
this but for years I’ve been watching a
lot of their videos.
I’ve been taking pieces, here and there
and there.
And sites like that are the reason why I’m
in the position that I am.
Lester: And I’ve learned so much from just
watching those Film Courage videos.
So kudos to you guys for giving us an opportunity
to learn.
Antoine: And the funny part about it, I used
to watch those videos and be like “I want
to be on Film Courage one day.
I have courage.”
And look now…I’m on Film Courage.
Lester: Right, right.
Antoine: Behind-the-scenes diary, original
series.
Lester and Antoine: Peace!